today's lunch monday episode is brought
to you by ftx ftx us they're basically
the coolest brand uh right now in all of
crypto they got great pricing they got
great liquidity and if you're interested
in getting into the stock beta go
download the ftxd go click on the link
in the description they allow you to buy
bitcoin cryptocurrencies and also stocks
all in one place in that beta of course
the reason why the stocks is interesting
is there's no trading fees there also is
no payment for order flow they coming
for wall street they also want to do all
sorts of cool things around derivatives
etc ftx they're now sponsoring lunch
money ftx us go check them out click on
the link in the description get an
account
and when you sign up they help you earn
all sorts of different rewards let's go
over the first topic jobs plano what is
uh what's going on with the jobs report
so the u.s economy added 390
000 jobs in may which is better than
they expected uh despite you know fears
of a recession economic downturn and
roaring inflation you can hear sophia in
the background singing um at the same
time the unemployment rate held at 3.6
percent just above the lowest level
since december 1969.
what do you guys think
hi sophia first off
i think she was saying hi to me
in particular
uh but what do i think about what the
jobs jobs are poor yeah 390 000 jobs you
weren't even listening i think i think
that there are 1.8 open jobs per
unemployed person in america way too
high
you're saying they should go get a job
yeah there's 11 million open jobs like i
feel like if you if you right now don't
like your job you should leave and go
get another one but but but but very
important if a recession's coming
don't quit your job and then go looking
for one go find the job first that's
like a very uh common rule i think that
it should apply all the time you would
be shocked
but also if there's times of uncertainty
coming companies like tesla are saying
we're going to cut ten percent of our
workforce the newest guys are uh are
honestly some of the best people in
position because they get paid the least
uh so they're normally very very
inexpensive to keep they can easily
progress and do the work of other people
that are in the company how about
coinbase uh they accepted some jobs and
then they rescinded the job offers oh
really yeah wait this is a topic for
later yes yes
you know what uh can i say one other
thing about the job situation go ahead
is that i think that a lot of the job
numbers are a little weird because uh
one of the things that
obviously has occurred is there's a
bunch of jobs that don't get counted in
the jobs report uh that are new so like
extreme example instagram model
not included podcaster not included uh
if you have a
sub stack not included if you are doing
like one-off consulting usually not
included if you're a uber driver not
included like there's an entire economy
that has been created that was not there
when they created the frameworks for
actually evaluating jobs unemployment
etc and so naturally that ends up uh
skewing the data a little bit right i
think we can look at the data and say
directionally but obviously there's some
things that could be better uber drivers
aren't included including this report i
don't believe so because i don't think
they're an actual w-2
uh
29 though they're 10.99 but like
do you have a job if you drive for uber
once a week and you get paid 100 bucks
yeah part-time
you're a contractor that's what 1099s
are for right but how does the
government get that data
right they have other jobs you're saying
well well maybe they do maybe they don't
how are you going to live off a hundred
dollars a week bro there's people who
live on fire and they can't they can't
wait till next year to get your tax
return to see where your income came
from they have to do that's not included
in today's data like you see what i'm
saying so like you start getting in this
like weird world where it's like let's
say for example that literally uh yeah
instagram model again like the extreme
example right is somebody's posting
pictures on the internet they build an
audience and whether they're a travel
blogger right or they're literally an
instagram model they're getting paid
they're able to live off of that they
don't report it until uh later on
usually a year right
that doesn't get included but like do
they have a job are they an entrepreneur
like
complex i also think that the uh uh the
salary expectations have shifted you
guys see that report yesterday that said
something maybe this is the topic sorry
paulina if it is but i don't see it on
there at least the uh uh the person was
uh
uh they said that i think it was one in
three people that are making 225k or
more are living paycheck to paycheck 36
yeah or yeah slightly over i guess 36
percent of people that are making uh
maybe it was 250 000 or more are living
paycheck to paycheck which sounds
absolutely insane uh relative to that
high level of income
the other
piece of it though is like is it just
because the salary expectations in like
psychology or is it because people are
just bad at managing their money
uh both
yeah
i i do think salary expectations have
drastically changed and we're we just
went from a market where uh it was an
employee-driven market to now we're in a
market that is an employer-driven market
and what you're going to start to see is
people are going to say i'd rather have
a job than the perfect job i'd rather
get
an income than the highest income right
i'm not going to hold out for the
highest income because like the opposite
is recession layoffs i need a job rather
than the best job that's basically the
opposite of what we've seen for the last
two years yeah i mean look this is for a
year and a half the federal reserve and
other central banks around the world
drove good times they got everyone drunk
and when everyone's drunk the individual
employees they're in control oh they're
doing all kinds of crazy stuff now
they're taking away the alcohol from the
party and when they do that
asset prices come down companies the
pendulum swings back now the companies
have more leverage uh and some of it's
because the companies need to have more
leverage like the company will go out of
business if in some cases they don't
fire employees they don't cut down on
their expenses they don't do certain
things and so naturally uh you could
make the argument again this is one of
many arguments that people will make is
if you have an uh a company full of 100
employees you can either say hey i'm
going to fire
10 20 of my staff
right and keep let's say 80
and those 80 percent of people get to
keep their job 80 out of 100 but 20 lost
their job or you can say hey we're not
going to fire anyone and then your
business goes out and now 100 people are
out of business right 100 people don't
have a job and so it's like in some way
like everyone always focuses on like
you're cutting and those people are out
but in some way you can make an argument
that you're also saving jobs
by getting your business in a place
where it's going to last so that the
people who remain are still employed
right and again i'm not arguing in
either way like
they're both things are true yes you cut
jobs and yes you save jobs but it is
because of a market force at play not
because
ceos wake up one day and they're like oh
last you know last year i really like my
employees this year i don't like my
employees let's fire them all yeah right
all right what's next
elon musk speaking of jobs uh he said he
sent an email and he said that he has a
super bad feeling about the economy and
he needs to cut about 10 of jobs at
tesla
so
he ain't really contributing to the
positively to the jobs number
what do you guys think
uh not really surprising right this kind
of echoes some of the sentiment that
he's said previously online about
the economy contracting we might be
headed into a recession he thinks uh
equities in general and other
financial markets were much higher than
they should have been so it's not
necessarily surprising to see him look
on his own business and say hey not only
should we not be hiring a bunch of
people maybe we should actually be
cutting
and the idea is like these cuts aren't
only reserved i think for companies that
are struggling because in some capacity
it's good to uh eliminate or trim some
of the workforce every once in a while
as the company continues to grow right
when you get thousands of employees uh
companies get too big they get bloated
and you have to start reducing roles
where you can and where it makes sense
to uh make the company more efficient or
reduce some of the uh processes or the
people that these these decisions touch
so uh not necessarily surprising we'll
see how bad it really does get i mean it
sounded like uh he was expecting
something pretty bad and we've already
seen a pretty steep drop in in financial
assets at least uh so it seems like
there's a lot more to go and it'll be
interesting to uh determine whether he's
right on this or not john were you
surprised
no just based off he even said months
ago that tesla was overvalued they're
still at i was looking right now they're
still at over a hundred p e ratio uh so
price to earnings ratio it's insane the
multiples that a lot of these companies
had over the last year it's obviously
going down drastically he thinks that
we'll kind of bring down everything i'm
sure there's still some supply chain
stuff he's looking at uh because he does
a lot of hardware things uh with
semiconductor chips and everything like
that uh yeah ten percent of your
workforce it's a big deal they operate
at i think like a 33
margin um which is double what other car
companies do uh so he's trying to keep
his margins high sales direct to
consumers stuff like that does that as
well but you got to cut costs where you
can
tesla has 100 thousand employees at the
end of last year and then yeah that's
the 10k yeah ten thousand employees uh
and someone made it globally globally
yeah globally someone made a good point
though in the chat they're like uh i
they you know they said i respect elon
but cutting and or firing people are
laying off people based on a feeling is
is uh
maybe a little uh rough right because
you're not really giving them a reason
outside of hey i have a feeling this is
gonna happen no i'm sure he's done
homework and he knows and understands uh
where the economy is headed
but at the same time like i don't know i
feel like you gotta at least give some
more reasoning than oh i have a feeling
let's cut ten percent but i think that
uh if i said to you right now why is
elon doing this it's like well he and
every other business executive in the
world pretty much is yelling and
screaming hey bad times are coming uh
make sure you have a strong balance
sheet make sure that uh you're in a good
financial position you know all these
things like
i don't think he has to give people a
reason
like that's the part that i think people
are confused again it goes back to
employee-driven market versus
employer-driven market like you have a
job right and so if he's sitting there
saying we need to cut 10 of our labor
force right he doesn't have to pull out
his macroeconomic analysis on it what
instead what he's going to say is we
need to cut ten percent of our workforce
because we need to have a strong balance
sheet going into a potentially
tumultuous time and therefore what we're
going to do is we're going to cut ten
percent of our workforce and get our
expenses in in check yeah but you still
have to have somewhat of a paper trail
of this is why i did this and this is
why i thought no i mean
be able to prove to be honest you don't
right he's the ceo of the business the
uh he gets sued by shareholders
maybe but ultimately like you know an
employee he can he has the right to fire
an employee if he thinks the business is
headed in the wrong direction from a
profit he can make up a million
different reasons right my whole thing
is it's just two different types of
managing people right you you have
employees uh and you're saying i'm
protecting the business doing these
things but a lot of that probably is
internalized and now he's saying i have
this feeling he's obviously done
homework on in some sense uh but i just
feel like i don't know not necessarily
the way i would do things i guess but uh
teach his own
i also think that uh he's said a lot of
things publicly that people are uh
inferring his thought process so even
though he didn't argue it right the
whole idea of like money was reigning on
fools
right or whatever he said uh and things
like recessions are actually a good
thing because it clears out the like
basically the inefficient companies
right one of the things that people
don't understand about uh recessions is
that during the good times there's tons
of bloat and froth that happens and so
you get a ton of companies that aren't
necessarily good businesses they stay in
business though because there's cheap
easy money flying around everywhere a
recession essentially clears out the bad
companies and so what you do is when you
clear out bad businesses those resources
both human capital financial capital etc
gets reallocated to the good businesses
and so his whole argument is that you
actually want to have recessions at
certain periodic points because it's a
culling of the bad businesses so that
resources can flow back to the good
businesses and you can continue building
i don't think that that's a crazy idea
that he is uh laying out here but to
your point maybe he could have made it
much clearer in the communication i
don't think he's worried about
explaining himself
i think he's trying to operate a
business and he's like let's get [ __ ]
done he just emailed his executive staff
saying get in the freaking office right
so he's clearly worried about the
direction that his company's going he's
been at the helm of this company for the
last 15 years uh 15 20 years at this
point and he's clearly done a very very
good job based off where they're valued
based off what their projections are for
this year um so if i was an employee i'd
listen to the man before you get fired
too
like i said he has every right to do
whatever the hell he wants to do it's
his business my whole point was really
just around uh treating people the right
way like you know people are losing
their jobs right it's uh a little more
difficult than just saying i have a
feeling you're fired
right crazy but
crazy all right coinbase plan what you
got for us
all right
so coinbase is another another one of
these companies that is announcing plans
to slow hiring to freeze hiring to
whatever but the crazy thing that
coinbase is doing is that they're also
rescinding
over like accepted job offers so they're
calling people and they're like hey we
know we offered you a job you accepted
it but sorry we're we're freezing hiring
right now
that's [ __ ] up
yeah like speaking of joe's point to
joe's point about treating people right
like i don't know because at this point
so here's the counter argument
is
i understand that it's a situation that
sucks
but
is it worse if the people that you just
got the job offers who haven't started
yet you basically have to pick either
you keep current employees
or you take on the new employees
right like it's a one-for-one like let's
just use easy numbers somebody gets paid
uh let's say a software engineer gets
paid on 150 000
and you've got an offer out to joe
and john works at the company any
company right
and i've got to cut
one software engineer
do i cut the new one that's incoming who
we hasn't worked here yet or do i cut
the one who already is my employee
like
again these are super complex things and
there's no right answer because if you
cut the new person as joe said like
that's [ __ ] up right that person quit
their job like there's a whole bunch of
issues with it but if you just instead
accept them and cut the software
engineer that's on your team already
like that's [ __ ] up too it's like
you're basically trading somebody on
your team for somebody new
and so like there's just really no good
and like these situations suck but but
to to play the contrary there you're
making it and either or in reality it
might not have been right you're saying
that they had to fire someone that might
not be the truth right the reality is
how many job offers did they really have
out to people that had already accepted
right it's not like it was thousands of
people
my guess is it's tens of maybe a hundred
plus people right probably less than 50
yes right and these are people now where
they said uh
most likely again we don't know the
people on these teams are going to have
to do more work we're not going to hire
we don't want to bring on additional
people in this in this situation
again that's a very small number in the
grand scheme of how big the business is
and all of those things so to accept
someone as a job give someone an outball
for have them accept potentially leave
their job maybe they did maybe they
didn't but say they did
and then go back and say
no i think that's kind of messed up but
uh again there's circumstances that we
don't know and maybe there's maybe
there's something that i'm missing i
don't disagree that it sucks
for the people who are on the receiving
end of this i wouldn't want to do this i
if this happened to somebody that i knew
a friend a family member whatever i
wouldn't want that to happen right i'd
be up in arms like i understand why
people are upset about it i think though
that uh
executives at every single company right
now are making decisions
that
they're basically faced with bad outcome
bad outcome
right and when you have to make hard
decisions like this it's really easy for
us to sit up here and talk and and
basically [ __ ] about this stuff it's
really easy for the media to write
articles and and say like oh look how
bad this is whatever but at the end of
the day it goes back to what's a
theodore roosevelt uh uh quote about the
man in the arena yeah anybody want to be
the uh the executive having to make
decisions right now who do i fire
no
anybody watching this if you've never
fired somebody that [ __ ] sucks and guess
what has anybody had to sit down and
fire five 10 15 20 people
right
during the 2001.com
uh crash i know somebody who told me
this story that they were firing they
had a very like 10 000 people uh in
their team there's a very large
corporation and they were having to fire
like i don't know a couple hundred
people and they were trying to do it one
by one now obviously you can't do it one
by one but how do we pick their top
people and go and and talk to them they
had security
in the office
because you don't know what somebody's
going to do you know they're mad right
they're taking away their livelihood
their livelihood like all like it's like
crazy crazy situation and so again i
always go back to the situation of just
like
having the empathy for both sides is
important i feel bad for the people who
have the job uh rescinded i have a uh i
feel bad for the people who are in the
process of getting a job right in the
interview process whatever bam hiring
freeze i feel bad for the people who get
fired and i feel bad for the people who
have to make these decisions because if
you ask them nobody wants to go to work
every day and make the decision as to
who do we fire today
everyone wants to do what we were doing
12 months ago which was
bugging up and to the right everyone's a
genius spending zone yeah just hey let's
go
nobody wants to do what they're doing
right now but this is part of building
businesses during bad times and so i
think that having a realistic
conversation about it is important to
understand the nuances um uh around it
all right plano what else
sorry i was on mute okay so tiger global
i mean
the the hedge fund lost 52
for the year through may
uh it's brutal out there this uh
tiger reported the drop which extends a
44 loss recorded through april and a
note to investors on thursday so can you
explain to us like how that exactly
works how what it works
so
what about investors like what does this
mean for investors so
i i don't want to uh
speak out of turn here because i read
the same article everyone else read uh i
can tell you what my uh understanding of
what's happening but i want to be very
clear that uh there's a lot of nuance
here this is somebody who read something
who's reporting on what's happening so
again could be inaccurate uh
obviously a lot of these tech ford
innovation forward growth stock you know
um uh type of hedge funds they're not
doing so hot duh stocks are all down um
and so tiger situation they're down 52
or whatever it is um
but as they had exposure to public
markets they also were plowing a lot of
money into private markets and normally
i'll make up numbers but like 80 20 or
maybe it's 90 10. 90 public market
exposure 10 private market exposure and
part of it is like hey let's go do
growth investing because these are
companies that are going to become
public companies so we're just going a
little bit earlier we're getting uh
better uh economics on it we can use our
knowledge from the public markets to be
able to invest in the late stage private
market
but what then happens is all of a sudden
your public market
uh
equities are coming down in value so
let's say they get cut in half you're
down 52 so you had 80
now it's the value 50 lower well if your
same exact uh private market stock which
was only 10 of your portfolio stayed the
same value let's just say it stayed the
same you went from uh let's say 80 20
to now all of a sudden you're at 40 uh
whatever it ends up being right so like
now it's a bigger percentage and as soon
as that happens what you get is you get
people saying i want my money back i
want to redeem give me my money back and
so my reading of the uh article was that
they're basically saying if you want to
redeem capital from us we are going to
give you some cash
and also we're going to create this new
entity we're going to put some of the
private investments that are not liquid
in that entity and then we will give you
shares in that entity so you get cash
plus shares in this new entity as part
of your redemption functionality now
hedge funds they deal with this all the
time they plan for uh redemptions they
try to disincentivize redemptions you
can't take all your money out at once
it's usually on a quarter by quarter
basis you only can take out a third a
fourth a fifth of your capital at any
one year like there's all these things
that they put in place
but
again part of the the dynamic at play
here is that the public market exposures
have dropped significantly in value the
private markets have become a much
bigger portion of the assets that they
have and so if somebody wants to redeem
this is like a unique way to give them
exposure to both public and private
markets and not have to give them 100 of
their cash back when they go through
that redemption process
they manage 80 billion and they lost 52
percent this year
it's crazy the s p is only down 12.
that's what happens
well also you can look and see uh how
they performed over the last you know
decade and they've outperformed that
yeah right so it's like yeah in the bad
time yeah not going so hot yeah
uh all right what else
okay so i know you're gonna think that
this is doesn't matter but i still think
it's interesting chipotle is now
accepting cryptocurrency payments at its
u.s locations uh and it's allow it's
working with this company called flexa
and it's allowing customers to pay with
98 different digital currencies um
so
do you remember what was that luxury
store was it gucci gucci that started
accepting kryptos payment
i still think that this is important
because of just
you know awareness and uh it's
bringing crypto to the public
i don't know awareness
what do you guys think
uh i agree that's cool to see uh places
like chipotle doing it the whole thing
is like we've seen these roll out from a
number of different places uh and
typically most people don't actually go
use it maybe that changes over time but
i still think that it's cool that
they're uh venturing down that route and
at least willing to accept it and if
you're a business like that why not
right we saw what happened with one of
the examples i always use is the
tennessee titans they
now accept bitcoin for payments for
season tickets for merchandise for all
these different things larger payments
at least uh and they're not keeping
bitcoin on their balance sheet they're
converting it so if you're a business
and you have demand in that currency or
with bitcoin or something else like why
wouldn't you set up the infrastructure
to take that money uh and i think that's
what we're seeing and we'll see over
time if maybe those those payments uh
trend upward
i tend to think that uh
this will drive
very little activity for chipotle but
it's a great marketing message because
they got us talking about chipotle yeah
i mean what do you think about them
listing a hundred coins though i think
that they somebody somewhere
somebody somewhere said uh we should
take crypto and they said cool go find a
company a vendor to do it and they went
and they found one and they said how
many coins you got and they think oh the
more coins you accept the better it is
yeah and they're like cool you do 100 we
want all 100 give give them all yeah
think about it now because now you're
like uh the headline is chipotle accepts
bitcoin and then the headline is to pull
accepts dogecoin the headline is
chipotle accepts ethereum you know
whatever you could uh you could spin it
a bunch of different ways which i think
is probably your wider point yeah i
agree all right what's the last thing
pelena
all right the national spelling bee was
last night i freaking love the spelling
bee um but
uh but basically it ended in a historic
way never before has there ever been
um a tie at the end so there was a spell
off so you had to spell as many words as
possible correctly in 90 seconds
and the person who won was um
an 8th grader named harini logan
um and get the sofia and talk about the
spelling bee and the winning word was
morehead so without looking can you guys
spell morehen moorhen
m-o-o-r-h-e-n
more hen correct
he looked it up he looked it up yes he
looked it up look at him
he definitely looked it up i'm just
smart as hell
okay so there's only really two ways
that i had to talk about spelling it you
spelled it that way i spelled it the
second way what did you say
m-o-o-r-h-e-n
[Music]
yeah that makes sense um wait wait uh do
you guys know what it is
no it's a medium-sized bird defined as
the female of the red ground sophia do
you want to see a medium-sized bird yes
there she is
are you a warhead
sophia how you doing paulina what do
they get for winning the spelling bee
they get 50 grand for win the spelling
bee but what like accolades do they get
pretty much accepted to any school that
they want like how does that work
probably there's a really great i don't
know but i know it's a cash prize but i
uh there's a great documentary on
netflix about the spelling bee
uh i forget what it's called but if you
type in it's so good so they get uh
fifty two thousand five
yeah fifty a little over fifty two
thousand dollars for first place in cash
they get four hundred dollars worth of
encyclopedias
what
second place gets 25k and third place
gets 15. you should give the losers
encyclopedias
say come back next year
you're an idiot there's only one
champion you're an idiot
polina thank you very much
thank you bye
bye hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time